hi there steve kaufman here again
answering some of your questions uh i
may not get to all of them but
the ones that i did notice
one question interesting question
would i talk about brain freeze in other
words sometimes
we know the word we know what we want to
say but we just can't remember the word
we can't say it and the more we try to
remember it of course
the more we ensure that we won't be able
to remember it
it happens to all of us
it happens to me at my age and sometimes
i think it's because i'm older now but i
think it happened to me when i was
younger as well and the more pressure we
put on ourselves i mean if we're at a
party and someone comes in and we're
trying to remember that person's name
the harder we try to remember the name
the harder it is to remember so i just
if i find that i can't think of a word
or i can't express what i want to
express i'll talk about something else
i'll move into a direction where i have
the words and gradually then come back
to what i wanted to say in any case i
don't let it upset me because it's
normal and the more confident and
comfortable we are the less pressure we
put on ourselves the less likely it is
to occur
there was a question from someone in
romania asking about how i would suggest
that he go about learning farsi because
there are no
resources well when i started learning
romanian there were no resources so i
went on the internet and i wrote up 200
sentences in english and i asked someone
to translate this into romanian and
record them for me i paid them for that
and the resulting lessons were imported
into link so if there are no farsi
resources you may have to create your
own another person asked how do i use
asimil
a lot of people like assimil
personally to me it's just another
beginner book like teach yourself
colloquial and what i get out of it is
strictly the lessons the content i
listen i read i used it for russian i
started using the korean one i found it
particularly uninteresting the russian
assimil has actually some interesting
content and to that extent is better
what i don't like about asimil is that
they don't give you the glossary in
other words the translations of the new
words they give you a full translation
which i find very distracting i find it
distracting to read in the target
language and then go reading through
english to see that particular word that
i'm looking for so i don't use asimil a
lot but i know that a lot of people do
like asi mail
so
basically basically that said fewer
questions i hope this is of interest to
you and now i got to get back to
studying polish
bye for now